the play magnus group was this your  transition  my transition wanted to be that it's  today they can still get the 50 off  exactly exactly  and great free uh materials also you can  watch on just just24.com  free so you can look around there you  can see a lot of  good quality content stuff  yeah you can get your free fix but you  of course want  what you want behind the payload  um  this game looks gorge  playing it out until the very end of h3  stop the pawns here excellent exactly  six hours ago they started this round  and what a fighting spirit finally they  can make moves without any  responsibility do you see how he moved  the pawn he doesn't have the strength  anymore to like pick it up he just  pushed it forward with this uh we have  to  clap these guys really tough